hey what's up my name's samuel leaves
welcome to winners on a wednesday
this week i got a guy this guy's gonna
blow you away
when i met him he had no property
experience nothing like that
and from scratch he's built a
rent-a-rent portfolio
of 27 rooms making him a clean
profit of two thousand seven hundred
pounds a month on top of that he owns
his own hmo
he's renting for twelve hundred pounds
he's made him and his associates have
made
fifty six thousand pounds from packaging
and selling dingles he's got a couple
big things going through right now which
he's buying with his
um money that he's made for sourcing and
from private investment joint venture
finance
so this dude is on fire patrick welsh
welcome to winners on the wednesday how
are you doing thank you very much thanks
for having me did i have to drag you on
the show
i i am sorry about that what happened um
a couple of attempts i think um going
back 12 months from now
i hit a point where i was making
probably
similar if not more than the two
thousand seven hundred pound
per month from the rental rents yeah
from the rent to rent business yeah we
had 32 rooms
at the time um which i'm self-managing
um so it kind of took over a little bit
uh
now at the time i wasn't at a stage what
i believe
what where i should have been or where
i'd like to be so unfortunately for
yourself
and and for me now yeah that kind of
yeah i kept messaging i kept saying
because you know you'd message me i'd
see you on the academy yeah and you'd be
like oh patrick's just done this deal
patrick's just done that deal
you know i knew it was coming from the
train yeah i'm like dude
why don't you come and see sorry and not
sure yeah you know maybe
camera shy maybe i don't want my my my
colleagues to see it in the workplace
and yes and that and the other
uh and you know what there's so many
people like that and you probably know
them
yeah of course i mean it's a bit of a
running theme really if it affects your
you your working life if you're still in
work and if
i suppose everyone's got their own
expectations of themselves
yeah me for one i i really want to be at
the top
and if i'm not feeling like i'm there i
don't want to talk about it until i get
anywhere near and especially recently i
said it's important to celebrate your
success yes
celebrate what you've done because you
always say to me i just want to be in
five grand a month i'm doing five now
okay i just want to be under seven
i do send that i just and you keep
so of all the different investment
strategies the property entrepreneurship
strategies yeah which one do you which
one are you guys passionate about
i'm most passionate about deal sourcing
really yes
interesting yep what is that we took a
shift from
um the end goal is to buy assets
which is why we all get into this for
passive income now
one of the routes that i'd chosen chose
to get onto that path
was a rent to rent business now which
went really well
started making good money um
deal sourcing i i started to do that in
the first lockdown
in march but i can just say you're so
good at deal sourcing thank you like
your deals
legit are very strong deals thank you so
you know anyway keep going um so we
started the sourcing company
uh around march time we did that because
what do you mean
what do you mean we um just me
myself and a couple of my associates
yeah but the thing is though
you've been cody or sourcing yeah in
fact you're doing a couple deals a month
yeah consistently you're making good
money one of the things i'm trying to
pull you away from is codial sourcing
yes that's right yeah
you're using my company yeah other
academy members yep your packaging deals
all right dude
that's what you do when you're getting
started your way past that now
yeah you're very good at getting deals
you've proven to yourself that you can
do it you need to start selling to your
own investors
that's it um i mean give me a deal and
i'll go and find it
um i do truly believe i can find
anything that you're looking for the
best of fun in deals
uh i also like working closely with with
investors sometimes what i've found over
the last
six months is um a lot of our businesses
come from people
overseas yeah not here to be on the
ground and not mainly that not only
they know what they've got chunk of
money they want to put it to work
it's my job to make them understand how
to do that
what to buy and what's going to come
coming out of the profit
yeah um i think some people you know
watching this might be surprised
at the amount of people that are in that
position
because the money the money in the bank
isn't just going to start losing money
yeah
so basically you've taken the skills of
being able to find investment properties
yeah
you're doing your own deals yeah but
you're making considerable amount of
money
by just selling deals on yes and the
great thing about being in that position
as a deal source as well so everyone
should be a deal sorcerer
is the best deals you can keep for
yourself i mean we've done that
we're doing that now as i'm sure we'll
come on to it
there's a couple of deals when you're
out on the road as you know yeah
they're they're ticked a few boxes yeah
you're putting out on your list
i want to know patrick what you
personally
have bought recently you patrick welch
yeah what you bought because you you do
some crazy deals what about the deal
you just put how much deposit did you
have to put down for that recent refurb
uh eleven thousand eleven thousand
because you're living there yourself yes
that's correct
so you sell that bad boy yeah if you
want you're gonna pay the capital gains
tax that's correct yeah you
you're probably gonna be financed that
um
as it stands right now we're probably
gonna refinance it use that money
to go and invest elsewhere so you bought
the house for
two one eight uh around that two fifteen
two
two eighteen you bought it four yeah
you're doing a little refurb on it yep
and then you're gonna either sell it
once if you refinance it what will
happen
if we refinance it we'll pull out around
40k um
so you'll pull out is this is this your
deal it's my we yeah we live there yeah
it's for me
you and your partner me and my fiance my
family
oh nice it's like a family home it is i
mean
um i'm slowly bringing my fiance into
this
um world um she was working two days a
week for a previous employer
yeah um she's now working for us
directly
the rent-to-rent business actually pays
her and replaces their wages and she
works for us now which is
a massive massive life-changing kind of
things happening here
yeah you know life changes i mean when
we first met
at the about you know back in what was
it about a year and a half two years ago
two years
june 26th when did you first start
watching my videos on youtube
uh probably the beginning of that 2019
probably
beginning of last year well now it's
2021 now it feels like 2020 still
yeah um so you're talking about almost
two years ago
yeah started watching the videos even
from the videos
you went and bought when did you
complete with your first house
uh we completed on that house it must
have been a day or two before
the crash course really yeah um
i mean don't get me wrong i was already
educated at the point of buying that
house
yeah off the back of your videos which
is free
yeah so um really you know picked out
the property
um and dr him wrong at the time
um we've we thought you know it was it
was fully let
now as an england inexperienced investor
that was that was a bonus you know i
don't have to find any tenants it was a
student accommodation
with four tenants in at the time by the
time we completed on it which was a
day or two before the crash course it
only had two tenants in
now what that meant was for the next 12
months is that
we the asts stipulated that
those only two tenants could rent the
house out for that generation
which is actually a 12-month asc
contract until the next
student intern came in you're kind of
screwed i want
yeah i was kind of screwed it kind of
washed its face uh in terms of profit
the the anticipated profit the agent
wouldn't put me any more tenants in
so i was kind of you know up against the
wall of it
um so i kind of just do you reckon you
should have bought the house maybe
a day or two after the crash course
instead of prior uh what i would have
done
is done a bit more work i'm actually
doing this now
second time around buying a another
property
that is talented i'm actually having my
solicitors work on it on a week-by-week
basis
yeah to get a rent account uh update
to make sure that everyone's up to date
and no one's in arrears covered arrears
all that type of stuff
and b that there's no things in place to
say that we can't run at
full capacity which is what hindered me
in this instance
so have you sorted that out now so now
it's sorted we actually switched agent
it's fully let 1200 a month from a four
bed and how much do you buy for uh
eight two three do you think it's gone
up in value now i think i think the one
next door
for like that i sourced one next door
but one
that's sulfur 99 okay so a nice little
juicy deal there
some room to be made in that one as well
at some point yeah so why did you join
the academy you watched the youtube
videos yeah and
you just said you were already educated
on youtube you came to the crash course
the crash course is free
why did you spend like 10 000 plus
pounds yeah
joining the academy you know going back
um i i i started off in my working life
um it's within me to be i thought to be
and just you know this house for example
the way you get is to be the best
employee as you can be now i went
through my
uh employee life going through the
stages and
incrementally getting to where on paper
where i thought was right
now i know in 2017
our finance director um sorry
before we get on to that bet i was
offered a position
that was you know a new position never
been there before
that was warranted a particular amount
of money
now me and my boss we we
agreed you know this is going to be the
rate this is you're worthy of it
it went up to the fd or kicked it out
and said
that amount of money uh it's too much
for a blue collar worker
so the penny dropped when i realized
that
i'm actually going to be dictated by
the color of you know the the status of
of the job financially and it's that
point i was laid in a hotel room in
london
and i've done a bit i've done a bit of
um you know podcasts and stuff up to
that point
kind of before i came across you
and at the time i knew but it was
usually i think you were talking about
video about no money down deals
no i was like oh god not this again i'd
heard about you know
raising jv finance and all these
different things so i was like i was
expecting you'd gone through three
options
jv finance i went through them all come
to the forefront you said lease option
agreements i'm like
that's funny i've not heard that one yet
i'm gonna do some more investigation on
you
and i just like you i like your energy i
like to use a similar age to me
um and start booked the crash course
rang my fiance and said we're going to
the crash course in june
um and the rest is history really stand
up to
the academy on the day of the crash
course was it a good decision
yes if my if my fiance weren't there
um probably think i don't think i would
have done it go on
well it was it was a similar situation
um to what alasdair has mentioned in the
past
sat next to her um you know
i was like do i do i i know if i put
myself in that position i'm probably
going to do really well
based on my track record throughout my
working life if i put that effort into
this
will that reflect um
i think at the time you know you got all
sorts of things going on and and then
she just
she just kind of turned and said you
know you've got to deal with that die
yeah
so off you're getting and
yeah signed up straight away what did
she think when you told her that she
could leave work
and work full-time in the business well
you know this weren't too long ago
um she would fail hard
and she was getting paid so when we come
out the back end of that she got made
redundant
we was happy i was happy just banking
the the profit you know and using that
as
um funds to to to increase the assets
and things like that
i just said you know don't worry about
it you want to be at home with our two
and a half year old daughter
um we have the facility now to make that
happen
i'll just redirect you ages up from our
business you know
and then you can the the two things you
want to get from it is
she's going to become educated through
what i do
and b i wanted to be productive yeah so
you know we'll get there but if she can
if she can come to a point where she's
finding me leads
she's doing reviewing she's packing your
stuff up ready for me to sell
um that would be ideal yeah and it's
tax-deductible and it's tasty dr paul
yeah so that's that'd be real that'd be
really good if we could achieve that how
does it feel being able to just give
give your fiance a job
yeah she she's it felt really good it
felt amazing yeah she
she's probably in tears um at the
thought of
uh we we actually told our daughter that
you know mummy didn't have to go back to
work
and i think that brought a tear to her
eye because
not many people can consider that they
don't need to work anymore
yeah for anybody else anywhere and you
guys are like what how old uh i'm 29
she's 28.
28. that's a great position to be able
to say that to your fiance
yeah 29 years old to be able to say hey
you don't have to go back to work
yeah exactly join the business it's
making good money
yeah 27 rent to rent rooms yeah
and that's cleaning your profit of 2000
is that your profit right now even
drawing all this madness
yeah so i mean as i say when we go back
to the beginning of it
so i aim for a hundred pound profit per
head
yeah so we had 32 rooms at the time we
were doing like
between three two and three five um
profit a month
profit a month yeah just from rent to
rent business yeah
covered hit now i was hit a little bit
on that
um which meant that uh for some reason
my uh the troubles came from some of the
lower end properties that would have had
universal credit tenants
right which don't make sense because
they're they get their rent paired
so um there was just more hassle that it
was worth i started to
start to get rid and hand back some of
the the lower quality houses
and it wasn't even anything really to do
with the house more area
so we're now focusing on i'm not i'm
downsizing the rent to run business
not not to not to sort of get rid of it
is to keep the
the ones that require as less as my time
as possible
and that that make the best money and
the the good they don't need any work
doing that so you just kept the best
ones yeah just kept the best one you
made from 2
700 every month yep managing it it's
really pretty
pretty smooth obviously it always comes
with work absolutely business
yeah of course it does i mean i
self-manage um as well
as well as um where can it work in a
full-time job
yeah so where are those properties
they're they're all in hull
and are they rent to hmos yes i'll rent
hmos there was already converted
yeah um the first one so when i started
your
so we did the launch pad and the rinse
revolution which is one of your academy
courses
first second third of august last year
yeah uh 2019 sorry
yeah um i think that was the august
i had the business set up in probably
like september
um now in terms of sourcing rent to rent
hmo what i did was
i mean you teach this as an individual
you are the freedom of information so
you can go to the councils
and ask them for the hmo register yeah
they send you a csv document
you log that into your into your doc
mill so that this is the the
the program that i use it's actually a
website it's a doc mail
um you load in a word document
pitching your idea of guaranteed rent
sent now i think i got i think i had 300
addresses to choose from
i thought this is going to cost me 60
quid
so i think i said i thought i'm going to
save half for the back end of the year
or
next year see how this goes so i chose
150 off the first half of the list
sent that out i got a reply from a
an old it's not even an ultimate face
he's about 40 years old he's just tired
he's been in a landlord since he was 18.
yeah um but really knows how to do a
conversion
and his standard of of conversion is
really high
so i walked into this place you know
rabbit in the headlights
um he didn't really didn't really care
about
my my pitch or anything like he just
said you know do you like it
yeah um
worked out actually you might remember
this just as i was gonna seal this deal
i did a voice note to you and you
replied because i was
i was trying to get an idea for it's a
seven bed um
property of this all ensuite gorgeous
house i actually messaged you saying you
know what do you think i should offer
yeah
um you come back and said let's just
like insult him i'm like i'm like
no okay so i played it tomorrow to chloe
and she said are you really going to
disagree with a millionaire
i'm like no so i insulted the guy
and he nearly pulled it
brilliant so but he gave me a benchmark
yeah
he gave me a benchmark to work from uh
we ended up going up
quite a little bit um well you got the
deal there right got the deal
it worked which meant that the caveat
was if you take this one i'll give you
another one
yeah so within the space of
prince revolution beginning of august by
october
i had 16 rooms so
that was very powerful in itself and two
of
them first two are the two ones i'm
keeping
five year deal we're keeping them all
the way just because that
you know touchwood they don't require a
lot of my time the tenants don't
they're sitting there most of them been
longer than six months
um and i'm not even really sourcing
tenants anymore
i'm using i'm i'm outsourcing it
better use of my time how much are those
two deals getting
per month profit then them two about
1800
it's incredible yeah that's incorrect
and you know what though the reason i
said that
i think my exact words were if
if um if you're not embarrassed yeah
yeah it's too hard
hey my advice to be someone else would
be exactly the same no you've done it
here's the thing patrick when you're
starting out in business as a property
entrepreneur
sometimes you can be a bit desperate to
get a deal and my fear
with people that are new to the new to
the gang is that they'll
they'll offer too high just to get the
deal yeah and then and then they're not
going to make profit because you've got
you've got to factor in your time
you know messing around with tenants so
you've got to make sure that you've got
enough
cushion in there to make a profit which
obviously you now are which is great
yeah um so the so so what happened then
then so you got those couple deals
off the back of the rental rent training
on the academy he then went on to do
uh like the buy refurbished finance
training hmo track
all the different what was the training
like on the academy training
is it's immense it speaks for itself you
only got to look at your
your students um every single person
that you have on here
they're making you know five ten fifteen
twenty thirty thousand pound a month in
profit
you you you're you're space you've
created a space
where people can do big business
and brag about it
in such a way yeah when you say i think
what you're talking about is
it's okay yeah to celebrate it i suppose
in your in your normal life
you're not gonna go you don't discuss
business matters with
you know your friends or family or
anything like that so
um that was hard for you that was yeah
you're from whole right
he still is if i'm totally honest yeah
i'm from i'm from hull
um and now what i've adopted over the
last sort of 18 months is
is is is relatively new still quite new
to me
um so it's just one step at time
obviously this is this is uh this is one
of those steps
yeah because you know what though most
people don't want to you don't want to
say to their friends
i just made 10 grand last week yeah
because their friends will resent them
so i guess because the space that i've
created
is where it's okay yeah we'll cheer you
one well everyone's doing it
yeah yeah that's right yeah everyone's
doing it everyone's doing
it it's normal yeah you're friends now i
mean you told me earlier you've
disconnected from a lot of your friends
um i mean naturally as you get older i
think you
you do anywhere yeah um but yeah i mean
he this i'm so busy who are your friends
now um
you yeah uh alistair yeah chris
yeah um they're all doing amazing
basically people on the academy yeah
that are winning yeah and then when
everyone's winning around you you can't
not win
yeah sure you just can't not win no no
and you said to me you were like dude i
need to come on winners wednesday
because it's
like all my buddies like all my buddies
have done it i feel left out now
yeah you know what my buddies have done
and i get why at first you're a bit like
has done two and a lot of people are and
i get that because
every time one person comes on winners
wednesday there's there's probably
there's probably 50 yeah that have
become financially independent yep
i mean i know i know a few people that
they've put a bit on the back burner as
well
um we're doing equally as good as as
good as what what i am so
but yeah it's credit to you training's
immense um
i recommend it to anyone if you want to
be in a high energy room
with good results on the day yeah which
i've done a number of times
made money at the deal selling mastery
um
alice destiny always brought a deal
brought a deal made three thousand pound
on on the dot
yeah their name what you just sold it
bank yeah where else can you do that
yeah so then it speaks for itself yeah
thank you mate i appreciate that and
it's been great seeing you know seeing
what you what you've done
uh talk to me a little bit about this
little refurb then how did you manage to
just put down 11 000 pounds
um just literally a nine to five percent
loan to value mortgage
because you're living there because i'm
living there um and
it it doesn't tie up a lot of cash um
obviously which we needed for the refurb
um i just a smart thing to do there's no
point in dumping a lot of cash into it
into a house
when it needs a lot of work i mean it
really does need a lot of work
um which we've done the nearly enough
done done the ground floor
we do it's a really high standard
because there's an element of us living
there and just refinanced it as opposed
to selling it
yeah so if we sell it we don't pay any
capital gains tax either so again that's
another another bonus
we've got a couple of options um which
which we're tying with
um yeah we'll see how that one goes
obviously with all this other things
that i've got on as well it's not a mad
rush to complete the refurb we've been
waiting for specialist parts and
and things like that so we'll just see
all that see how that goes we've got a
couple of big deals going through as
well
hmos yeah um buying
a seven bed uh property which is
uh sorry it's been it's been a it's in
prime location here five in hull
um you're due to complete any day now
due to now january 10th you should be
completing
january yeah um i think the due to
exchange maybe next week or something
like that
yeah um which and it's full fully
rented thirty thousand pound a year that
house is making uh
and and what's the purchase price of a
grade one five nine that is incredible
yeah i think
i'm gonna run it myself now for a bit
anywhere is it in hull
yes it's like it's like 10 minutes worth
what's all like as an investment area
it's probably um been better
but i think it's coming back around
again hmm um
did samuel lead saturated literally
solely your responsibility
thank god i've not done a financial
freedom challenge there um
what i like about hull yeah i mean i'm
deal sourcing so i know
most areas um quite well now
hull's got a really high return on
investment no it's because the purchase
price is
quite low i mean you can take that house
what i've bought now so that
159 purchase price 30 000 pound a year
rent
you take that house put in doncaster
that's going to be worth
260 yeah which is going to drop your
right you're still going to make the
same amount of rent
yeah um fair enough clientele might be
not
as great but i mean i'm going to choose
them people because i'm going to
i'm going to ultimately have the final
say i might not do the viewing
but i'm going to get the the paperwork
through vet the tenant
reference and things like that so yeah
what's it like owning multiple
properties
making thousands and thousands of pounds
a month in your 20s in property
stressful
obviously this is not easy no it's not
she's not get rich
quickly get wealthy over a period of
time put the work in and then live the
life that most people can't
yeah so i mean what's it like so it's
it's
it's bit bittersweet really it's like
you you need to go through it to come
out the other end
um and i have this i have this uh
kind of saying that it's a bit brutal
but i say if you're not growing
you're dying so if i'm not pushing
myself on a monthly basis on a daily
basis
you know weekly i'm taking on new deals
um then what am i offering yeah and i'm
not going to get to where i need to be
so yeah it's amazing being in the
position i am
um i'm 29 now
if i have if i could change one thing is
that did this ten years ago
i would be in different position right
today but you know what though when you
were 27
what would you have thought if you'd
have known that in two years time you'd
be where you are now
uh i'd be really happy really happy with
with the result
i mean i could probably have said you
know i hope in in
in two years time i'm at stage x y and z
um and i'm probably really happy with
the result
because you're a hungry person so you're
always wanting yeah to go to the next
level
you have to be obsessed to
get remotely close to what you think is
acceptable
or to where you need to be yeah and
that's how to measure it i mean if
you're not obsessed
expect medium hot to low results it's as
simple as that
yeah if you if you want to make two
thousand pound a month in property and
you want to do that over a two year
period
yeah all right no problem yeah you want
to make serious money yeah build up
serious wealth in your 20s
you have to roll your sleeves up and you
have to go to work yep and
some people don't get that some people
aren't created to do that and that's
okay
some people come to me there's even
people on the academy they're making two
and a half thousand pounds a month
and that's all they want and then they
just live a nice quiet life
they quit work and they just plod along
yep and for them
they're happy yeah course but then other
people like you you want
more all the time well you speak to some
people you know
you have the same conversation and i
might have a similar
uh long-term goal to someone else and
if you look at if you measure what
you're putting in place to get there
sometimes it doesn't reflect and that's
one of the most
the most important things is to
acknowledge what are you doing about it
yeah because you know implementation is
the key
to to get into it to where you need to
be let me ask you a question patrick
you're very hungry very motivated he's
doing crazy things most people wouldn't
dream of doing what you've done in your
20s
what's what's your reason for doing this
what's your strongest reason why the
strongest reason why
is ultimately i'm giving
my daughter the life um i mean i i've
done all right life i'm
not that i've come from from poverty or
anything like that not you know
nowhere near but i want to give my
daughter an opportunity that i never had
um all of my my businesses are named
after my daughter
um and what's his name eden great name
businesses at eden property so um
yeah not that i'm going to hand her a
business or anything like that i'll
handle a portfolio of houses it's just
where
um get taught
that you know from an early age that
this is this is um
what i've done yeah this is an option
for me to offer you the you know and
teaching culture down the right routes
obviously and and provide a bit of
freedom for myself and
chloe so yeah whether that's travelling
when when all this is
this is over with um we want to
we want to do all those types of things
so
yeah i think the best gift you can give
your kids i mean i've got um
two kids the third one's you next month
god willing congratulations thanks man
but you know what the best thing you can
give your kids is not money
yeah it's showing them an example of
what is possible yeah giving them a path
giving them an opportunity
um passing them your personal
development
education that you've learned and you've
paid big money for um
you know so i mean that list is growing
we've i've done further training since
then
yeah yeah um you're constantly because
you like you said you're obsessed with
growing
yeah so you're not gonna go right i've
done this in that course now you're
going to be constantly
reading new books and telling new
seminars yeah you're going to be
constantly
stretching yourself yeah of course i
mean you you have to um
what i have realized is i mean right in
the beginning you think
you look at how how much these things
are and you only got to look at
um the progression that people have made
who have been on
yeah i mean if you want if you want to
uh
if you want an idea of what you're going
to get from it just look at the people
that have done it
simple as that um fair enough for some
people that don't succeed but you've got
to look at what they've
they've put into it yeah what comes out
the other end yeah and you've got to
look what the majority of people are
getting
yeah you know what the vast and and yeah
exactly i mean
what's um i mean you asked me you asked
me off camera you're like
how do you deal with the flack i said
i'm taking him on for the team you did
here
like what what what as an academy member
someone that's in it obviously
i get there's people on the sidelines
speculating yeah you know what as an
academy member
someone that's totally in even well
invested
how is that how's that for people like
you i i know you
um quite well now for
you know a year or so properly and i
think i think you're genuine
um hasn't crossed my mind once any of
the
crap that gets that gets said i think if
anyone's got an opinion
um i would make a suggestion
that they don't know yeah and they've
had no dealings with yet and they've not
paid for any training and they're also
not doing
as much as what they they could be if
they took the training
yeah yeah that's that's the best thing i
can say you know it's the
the training is it's immense and you get
big results
yeah i appreciate that what was it that
made you um
come for this interview um i think
finally people people uh investors in
this space they need to know
uh who i am yeah from my business
because you've been hiding away too long
uh i'm a victim of hard and aware
i i used to be of the mindset that my
work will always do
the talking yeah but as we quickly
established
people if people don't know who you are
they don't know how good you are as a
deal source and these different things
yeah it's not good to anyone yeah so
and i guess you were seeing some of your
friends that were like putting
themselves
out there yeah i mean uh there's you
know coming on the winner's wednesday
show sharing their story and you're like
man i'm passing them my deals yeah
they're like chris so so chris has
exposed
a number of times on your channel you
know you've said
because he's got like 20 rent to rent
deals or whatever it is
um therefore he's known for that um
which
gives him customers investors therefore
his database is bigger than
than mine because i've not been i've not
put myself in that situation and i
suppose today's
is about that yeah yeah and also you
know what
i remember that property you were like i
found this property and chris sold it
and then chris told it to someone and
that person only knew who he was because
of when it's wednesday i was like dude
you need to just come on the channel
and i'll tell you how that happened yeah
um we was having a phone call about
the the the covered
march madness with tenants disappearing
and all that type of stuff
um we both was chatting about deal
sourcing
so i said chris i i can find anything
and he's like well it's funny because
i've got investors that need
deals so i said give me an example said
i've got one
investor she wants a biary february
finance
to hmo deal i'm like give me give me
like a week
we secured it um
i think it was a couple of
a couple months ago now coming towards
the end of the refurb yeah
that's gonna leave in the deal on
refinance
less than 10 10 000. um
it's gonna cash flow a thousand pound a
month incredible yeah so
so that that came from me but what i'm
getting at is he had an investor
sat waiting for that based off exposure
and i could find the deal and that's we
just married the two
yeah what was the what was the what was
your biggest
tip for people or what was the like the
training program
yeah that really accelerated you as a
deal finder that made you able to find
these deals crunch these numbers like
what was it
deal selling mastery yeah it's amazing
um
because you do it live yeah it's not
like a
sit down with a book read the book tell
me what you've learned and go home and
do it it's
i'm going to tell you i'm going to show
you i'm going to sell on stage
i think we sold like 24 000 pounds worth
of deals
yeah over two days that's that propelled
me that that course
because it was mo it was more of a
reiteration of
what i'm doing do i need to change
anything is there anything you need to
put in place yeah
um yeah really really good that's sick
also tell me
people want to get in touch with you
yeah what's your website we need to know
uh eden propertyinvestors.com uk
awesome i'll put a uh a link in the
description thank you
and final final words of advice for
someone that's thinking about getting
started on property
next steps what do they need to do you
just need to get started
um you need to invest in yourself it's
the biggest investment you'll make
you'll make
that back tenfold
and like i said before remember this if
you're not growing
you're dying yeah you're just stagnant
that's true man yeah you've got
if a flower was not growing it's dying
and we're no different
it's great to see what the virtual
property investors crash calls and
last but you keep coming back to the
crash courses yeah it's a good space to
be in
um as i said like-minded people
networking that type of stuff
um you just got to be there and then
plus it
reiterates everything that i mean i'm
the last time i was there was 12 months
ago so it's just uh
you know driving that nail a little bit
was it good when you came back
last month it was amazing yeah yeah
really really good that's awesome man
hey listen
keep up the good work but i need
anything obviously anytime give me a
shout i know we've been we
bounced voice tonight back back and
forth and stuff but uh now mad respect
for being on the show
guys i hope you found that inspirational
i hope you found that practical
filled with golden nuggets if you want
to come to the property investors crash
course the same course
that got patrick started it's on the
house it's free i'll leave a
link in the description where you can
get yourself booked on for free and come
and learn all the nuggets
and everything i've learned over the
last 12 years in property you can learn
for free
if you want to watch more interviews
like this every single week i
interview one of my students that's
killing it in property and every time i
interview someone it represents probably
about 50 people
and i've got over 100 interviews right
here from my success students
also please don't forget to subscribe to
the youtube channel you can do that
right here so you don't miss a future
video
thanks for watching i'll see you next
time